I meditate two hours every single night
a lot of people talk about discipline
okay great why do you fall off the wagon
why can't I continue with this routine
going to the gym being better waking up
early eating the right Foods is because
maybe it's your kids maybe it's your
wife maybe it's your job and it's all
just stuffed in your brain you don't
have it compartmentalized and organized
in these nice shelves so where am I
gonna put discipline in that mind if I
can't find other you gotta be able to
find all these different things in your
mind oh I can put discipline right there
I can put consistency right there I can
put all these things right there in that
spot if your life is not organized in
your life being everything around you
because it takes one little the piece of
an outside interference to clutter your
whole mind because it's on such a knife
edge that's right and people don't get
that your mind has to always be clear
that's why